assassin's creed valhalla is a fantastic
game that plays wonderfully
with its setting and time period but
there's a lot to 873
a.d britannia that's glossed over or
there's tiny anglo-centric details and
wrinkles in the world
that may not mean too much to those
players that were born beyond the
borders of these british isles
9th century england was a weird place so
i'm here to try and give you a little
background to the kingdoms you'll travel
through
and the island on which you'll settle so
if you fancy something that is half
history lesson half video game breakdown
then i've got just the thing for you
so why is 873 a.d england in four main
pieces with four rulers in assassin's
creed
well as rome withdrew from britain in
1410 ad
they left a fractured political
situation and as such the person with
the largest band of fighters was able to
hold the largest pieces of land
by 650 a.d seven micro kingdoms had been
claimed by their chieftains or y'alls
these were bernarcia diera lindsay east
anglia mercier wessex and
kent they were again consolidated and
conquered to become the four kingdoms
that make up england in assassin's creed
valhalla
northumbria murcia wessex and east
anglia
and the country would remain this way
until 9 27 a.d
feuds between kingdoms would continue
and as such this was a chaotic part of
history for england
and the invading and settling danes took
advantage of that to install their own
puppet kings onto the thrones of petty
kingdoms
an element that is reflected in the
story of protagonist aval
many of the rulers are represented in
assassin's creed valhalla as well
one of those being the big bad from the
original valhalla trailer
alfred the great was a king that had
inherited a reign from his brother
alfred the first who spent his entire
rule fighting the
viking waves of the great heathen army
and while alfred the great was
considered a learned and merciful man
and an all-round strong ruler it's
unsurprising that the game paints him in
more of a dour light
considering the story's need for
antagonists and the division between
the danes and anglo-saxons
nearly every assassin's creed game has
featured a variety of languages within
its story
and valhalla is no different the
historical languages that make an
appearance in this game represent the
type of people within the isle of
britain
the main three as seen in the game are
anglo-saxon old english
the west germanic language that came to
england alongside post-roman settlers in
the 5th century
old norse which was brought in by viking
invaders and contained a few
similarities to old english
as they both stemmed from the
proto-germanic mother language from
mainland europe
and of course not to be left out there
is also latin all three have some
representation within the in-game world
firstly within the locations that you
visit for example grant and bridgeshire
one of the earliest areas you'll visit
in the game
becomes modern day cambridgeshire the
name grantbridge comes from the nearby
river grant
and the word shire in old english
denotes an official charge or district
under a governor
and grew to mean shia or county
accurately reflecting the trading post
commanded by the in-game character soma
snottinghamshire don't laugh this is
serious history
was a name that didn't appear until 868
but
breaking the name down in old english
reveals the history of its name
snot was the name of an anglian
chieftain inga
meant the people of and ham meant
homestead
it may have grown into modern nottingham
but the name as it stands in
assassin's creed valhalla is simply the
homestead of the people
of snot nice a couple more quick ones
too modern-day sussex which is spelled
somewhat differently in assassin's creed
is seemingly made up of suth meaning
south and seax which was saxon
becoming land of the south saxons and
off the back of that
i'm sure you can guess essex and wessex
and oxenford which may not surprise you
to learn
is the forward of the oxen isn't
language fun
further north in the map is where you
start seeing influences from overseas
much of the wandering populace will be
speaking norse and of course one of the
most prominent cities in the game
jorvik which is modern day york holds on
to its scandinavian moniker ravens
thought the settlement which you build
up through your time in game
also retains a normic naming structure
the word thorpe in
old norse translates to a secondary
settlement
which if you've played more than a few
hours of the story you'll know that's
exactly what that small town is
latin however seems to be reserved for
the christian clergy in the game
you can hear them speaking it if you
blend in with their groups at certain
locations
like london ambulatory
a place which still holds much of the
ancient roaming naming conventions
such as the londonium amphitheater while
the titles used for some of the named
anglo-saxon enemies don't appear in
history until
sometime beyond the 9th century setting
of assassin's creed valhalla there are
however historical tidbits that reflect
your enemies and their combat style
yeomans for example were a social
standing above the common peasant or
foot soldier
but lower than knights as they were
commonly used as guards and were better
trained
this is reflected by their sturdier
shields and defensive posture in game
gedrick were the personal followers of a
chieftain and was sworn to die with him
as such they'd commonly get access to
better supplies such as helmets
and chainmail and were professional
soldiers by trade
again reflected both cosmetically and
existing as much tougher enemies than
the normal soldiers you face
and a banaret was a type of knight with
the right to lead a company of troops in
a time of war the in-game enemy wielding
a greatsword and covered in armor
goes some way to creating that nightly
vibe but when it comes to the leading of
men
they also have the special ability to
command nearby saxon archers
to fire a full volley at evil
the tradition of flighting seems to have
derived from the gaelic phillips social
class
of professional poets but the word
fighting actually comes from an
old english verb philtan meaning to
quarrel
but was performed as a ritualistic
exchange of insulting poetry from as
early
as the 5th century while you were
introduced to the pastime on the shores
of norway
it is not a completely nordic phenomenon
as you see through the towns of
assassin's creed that both dane and
saxon alike take part in the swapping of
hot disses
there is also literature documenting
nordic gods taking part in flighting
with loki in particular insulting the
other gods
in the anglo-saxon epic of beowulf the
titular character uses flighting as a
prelude to battle
or as combat in its own right and
shakespeare even wrote instances of
flighting
into many of his comedies one aspect of
fighting that assassin's creed plays
upon however is the jovial and often
good-natured intention of the verbal
back and forth performing well will
almost always get supportive responses
from whatever oath you just
linguistically put down
and historically in anglo-saxon england
the contest of wits would often take
place in a feasting hall with the winner
being decided by the reactions of the
crowd
and finished with the winner quaffing
enlarge mead and graciously inviting the
defeated party to drink along with them
as well
this has not only been faithfully
co-opted into a fantastic mini-game in
the world of valhalla's england
but also goes some way into showcasing
the importance of poetry
and intellect in medieval cultures this
goes hand in hand with hearing aval
performing their own intimate poetry in
cutscenes
and out in the world as well as crew in
your longboat using word and wit to
entertain the other vikings rowing
alongside them
there are also some lesser known and
unlived locations that are a big part of
british history
but may be unknown to those who hail
from further shores hadrian's wall for
example is a former defensive
fortification of roman britannia
built around 112 a.d during the reign of
emperor hadrian
an 80 mile long wall of varying height
and thickness it was built to guard the
wild northern border from the picts
a group of celtic speaking people who
lived in what is today
scotland as aval heads to the most
northern reaches of assassin's creed
valhalla's england
you may choose to visit some of both the
crumbling and still withstanding
sections of the wall
if you choose to journey across the
whole thing and like the brazilians as
you go
you'll be awarded with the achievement
is anyone out there and while historic
accounts of the purpose of the war vary
theories relate to the policy of defense
and hadrian's biographer wrote that the
hadrian was the first to build a wall
80 miles long to separate the romans
from the barbarians
indeed parts of this war still stand
today the larger sections being
preserved as part of the history of
britannia under the roman empire
although parts are also missing as
up to the 19th century farmers were
straight up stealing the stonework
to build their own farm walls another
more esoteric site can be found on the
hills of sussex as
aval roams the southern countryside the
long man of wilmington or the wilmington
giant
is in the real world a 235 foot tall
figure of a man holding two staves
its origins however remain unclear it
has previously been thought to originate
during the iron age or even neolithic
period
but 2003 archaeological investigation
may have shown
that it could have been formed during
the 16th or even 17th century
it is indeed one of britain's most
mysterious residents but a figure that
has been theorized to be a fertility
symbol or even an ancient warrior
is now a tourist attraction protected
cultural site
and a figure that a football team
vandalized and painted a giant knob on
back in 2010 and of course a site that's
likely familiar
to many stonehenge in valhalla it exists
both as a landmark and as one of the
game's standing stone puzzles
rewarding you with xp and a skill point
on its solution
unfortunately avor shed no real world
light as the true purpose to this
prehistoric
monument it remains however one of the
most famous landmarks of the united
kingdom
and a world heritage site it was built
by a culture that left
no written records so its purpose and
method of construction
are still debated and theorized maybe it
was those isu
alien folk from the game that made it
however one unfortunate note is that you
cannot
parkour over the real world version
while there are many more historical
tidbits hidden within aval's adventures
that's about all we've got time for
today
and i've yet to even find all of them
myself i hope you enjoy this weird mash
of history lesson and video game lore
exploration
if you did be sure to let us know in the
comments and tell us about your favorite
site in assassin's creed valhalla as
always like the video
and for more like this be sure to
subscribe to gamespot
you